اذا اخذنا الصوره ايضا الى هذه المجموعه
من المتطوعات والمتطوعين سالناهم ماذا
تفعلون كان الجواب انه في هذا المخازن
توجد المساعدات التي تاتي من كل المحافظات
التركيه الى الجامعه هم يقومون الان
بتوزيع هذه المساعدات على عده انواع مثلا
في كل كرتونه ماذا يوجد فيها
معكرونه يوجد
طماطم ثم بعد ذلك
مواد غذائيه وهي في طريقها
نعم وهي في طريقها كما اخبرونا الى القرى
والبلدات المجاوره
للمدينه بالاضافه ايضا نجد هذا البراد
الصغير الى هذه الكميونات هنا العشرات من
الاطنان او لربما يكون عشرات او مئه طن
تقريبا من العبوات ومن المياه ومن المواد
الطبيه ومن المواد الغذائيه ومن الالبسه
بالاضافه ايضا الى عدد كبير كان من الجيش
الذين يقومون
بوصول هذه الشاحنات هم يقومون مباشره
بتفريغها على الارض ثم بعد ذلك تقسيمها ثم
بعد ذلك توزي